hulu has put out a ton of fantastic
original movies over the last few years
so many in fact that it could be hard to
know where to start
well fear not because these are the best
hula movies you can't watch
anywhere else bad hair starts off pretty
unassumingly directed by justin simeon
of dear white people fame
the movie follows anna a woman who
decides to get a weave in order to
become more successful in the world of
music tv
so far so normal right but things get
kind of weird after that
first when anna discovers that her hair
is somehow moving on its
own and then when she begins to have
some very strange dreams indeed
ultimately anna's hair grows a life of
its own and begins to terrorize the
people around her
although the premise may seem absurd bad
hair is also a clear-eyed critique of
the way beauty is dictated by standards
that tend to be overwhelmingly white
in getting a weave anna lets those
standards take control of her life a
metaphor simeon literalizes in the text
of his film
this is simian's first foray into the
horror genre and one that's
more than worth 90 minutes of your time
rapper takashi 69 has left a huge
impression on popular culture
despite his youth so maybe that's why 69
the saga of danny hernandez
caused such a stir upon its initial
release this documentary film
explores the controversial rapper's life
story including his rise to prominence
in the world of music
his continued affiliation with street
gangs and his several arrests
hernandez's story is just about crazy
enough to be worthy of a documentary
although director vikram gandhi is
limited by the rapper's refusal to
participate in or
cooperate with filming gandhi gets
plenty of great footage from the people
who know hernandez best
but without speaking to the rapper
himself it's impossible to get the
fullest
possible sense of who he is even so the
saga of danny hernandez offers up
plenty of insight into its subject's
growing fame and
what it means for both him and the
people around him
there's a good reason why hugely
successful con men are such compelling
subjects for documentaries
in retrospect it seems obvious that the
entire illusion they created was built
on house of cards
which only makes the fact that someone
was able to pull the whole thing off
even more compelling wework or the
making and breaking of a 47 billion
dollar unicorn
provides an in-depth look at one of the
biggest corporate busts in american
history
telling the story of the rise and fall
of wework and its ultra-charismatic ceo
adam newman
the film chronicles ways in which newman
was able to convince his employees and
investors that the company was worth
billions more than it actually was
thanks to a number of interviews with a
wide range of different people
this documentary is able to articulate
precisely just how newman pulled one
over on
everyone although it was criticized for
failing to examine the broader culture
of capitalism that facilitated newman's
scam
the documentary is nonetheless a
compelling analysis of exactly how
wework came to be
and why it all went so wrong
in boss level frank grillo plays roy
pulver a former soldier who is trapped
in a time loop of the day that
invariably ends with his death
over the course of the movie pulver has
to unravel the government conspiracy
that played a role in his own murder
and take down a villainous colonel
played by mel gibson
what the hell let's take this to the
next level
much of what you'll find in boss level
is exactly what you'll find in any
standard action movie but the addition
of the time loop element makes all that
conventional plotting feel impressively
fresh
what's more grillo usually a supporting
player in these kinds of action movies
takes on the lead role here and doesn't
waste a second of screen time
and sure the movie may not be high art
but hey
not everything needs to be there's no
shortage of stories about what it's like
to grow up
famous some look at the experience as an
incredibly exciting and
enviable adventure while others lament
the loneliness of the celeb lifestyle
but kid 90 offers a uniquely on the
ground account of what it's like to grow
up on the silver screen
the movie features archival footage
taken by solay moonfry who became famous
as tv's beloved punky brewster
as it turns out fry carried a video
camera with her everywhere she went
throughout much of the 90s
and so managed to capture all the trials
and tribulations of young startup
the documentary features interviews with
a number of stars and celebs including
fry herself
on what it was like to grow up with a
famous space during the 90s
between all that archival footage and
all those interviews
kid 90 paints a compelling portrait of a
group of people
who grew up in the spotlight and had to
deal with the consequences for the rest
of their lives
it's not often that a great actor is
able to truly embody an iconic
role in fact the sad truth is that
sometimes the performer just
isn't a good match for a particular
character in becoming bond
filmmaker josh greenbaum examines one
very particular era of the james bond
franchise
in order to take a closer look at the
relationship between character
and actor specifically greenbaum focuses
on the career of george lazenby the
australian actor who only portrayed bond
in 1969's
on her majesty's secret service this
never happened to the other fella
the film uses reenactments of scenes
from lazenby's life
as well as actual footage of interviews
with the actor to examine why he took on
the role of bond
and why he eventually decided to leave
the role after just one film
and while lazenby's time as james bond
is an interesting enough chapter in the
character's onscreen history becoming
bond covers far
more than that it also flips the script
by exploring the way that the bond
character
influenced lazenby's own life and how it
ultimately shaped
every role he took on afterwards thanks
to her passionate efforts to raise
awareness about climate change greta
thunderberg has become one of the most
famous
activists in the world citizens of every
continent have watched her speak at the
un
or followed her as she traveled across
the world by boat
i am greta however offers a more
intimate look at duenberg's efforts to
convince the world that the climate
crisis
is its number one problem the film was
knocked slightly for its lack of truly
revelatory insights into toonberg
herself but
it's clear from her public persona that
she's not really interested in hogging
any glory instead she's focused on an
issue that she sees as an emergency
and the documentary makes it clear that
her mission is much more important
to her than any specific details about
her own life regardless of whether you
learn anything new about her or her
cause
i am greta should help you understand
why her activism has been so
transformative for so many people
weirdly enough what the amazing jonathan
documentary really gets at is what it
actually means to make a documentary
the movie's director ben berman follows
the amazing jonathan a magician dying of
heart disease on his final tour
that somewhat simple setup may sound
conventional enough but this film has
a number of twists each of which builds
upon the others until it becomes
almost impossible to discern what the
truth being presented
even is part of what makes the amazing
jonathan documentary work
so well is that it seems to recognize at
least in part
how foolhardy it is to try and find the
truth while you're pointing a camera at
someone the movie argues that truth is
always
illusory and that this is especially the
case when the subject has their own
agenda
with the tricks that it manages to pull
off the amazing jonathan documentary
turns the concept of truth on its head
and proves that magic doesn't always
have to be sleight of hand
although many of hulu's most successful
projects are documentaries its narrative
films have also enjoyed a great deal of
acclaim
little monsters for example is one of
the streaming services most popular
movies thanks in large part
to a hugely memorable performance by
lupita nyong'o
the movie tells the story of a
kindergarten teacher who has to defend a
group of children from an impending
zombie apocalypse as you might imagine
things quickly get gory
messy and bizarrely adorable obviously
there are a whole horde of zombie movies
out there but little monsters manages to
put a fresh
spin on many of the genre's most
well-worn tropes
as a horror comedy it can take certain
tonal liberties other films can't
and makes thorough use of this
opportunity too moreover little monsters
serves as definitive proof that nyongo
is as skilled at comedy as she is at
drama
and acts as a delightful counterpoint to
her more serious horror work
all in all this is the kind of offbeat
enchanting movie that doesn't often get
made in hollywood these days
especially in the world of zombie horror
few things have had a bigger impact on
american culture than barbie and
tiny shoulders rethinking barbie
explores the parts that this iconic toy
has played in an ever-changing world
honing in on one specific item
especially a toy might have restricted a
lesser work to shallowness
but tiny shoulders uses this focus to
deftly examine how western standards of
beauty have changed over the last few
decades
barbie has contributed to a number of
shifts in culture but she's also
followed them
and often does both at the same time
suitably then
tiny shoulders follows mattel as it
prepares for the doll's biggest
reinvention
ever the movie features interviews with
a number of feminists
media commentators and even mattel
insiders and
tackles the vital importance of barbie's
role as a lightning rod in american
culture
the fire festival may have been the
absolute peak of 2010's
scammer culture and fire fraud tells the
full story in
excruciating detail in case you didn't
know this 2017 festival
promised to be one of the most exclusive
parties of the year
promotional material depicted the event
as one absolutely
dripping in luxury but when the day of
the festival actually arrived
those promises failed to materialize now
total chaos has erupted
fans are fleeing the fire festival on
emergency flights
out of the bahamas by focusing on billy
mcfarland the entrepreneur at the center
of the fire festival plan
fire fraud really gets to the rot at the
heart of the event
specifically it asks how he managed to
convince the world that he knew what he
was doing
even when he really really didn't the
documentary spends plenty of time on the
build up to the festival
but it's definitely not time wasted as
the payoff is almost
ludicrously sweet the fire festival
scandal was broadly publicized
as it happened but the documentary
exposes the event's horrible conditions
in even closer detail
fire fraud also gets at something deeper
about the culture mcfarland exploited
by suggesting that people are most
easily fooled when they're offered
something too glamorous to pass up
when you think of kristen stewart you
probably don't think of quirky rom-coms
but if happiest season is
any indication maybe you want to this
charming movie stars stewart is abby and
mackenzie davis as harper a couple who
journey to harper's family home for
christmas
there's just one problem harper's
straight-laced parents don't know that
their darling daughter is a lesbian
as a result abby has to pretend that
they're just close friends
even though she's been eagerly planning
to pop the question on christmas morning
happiest season plays into a number of
tropes found in the romantic comedy
genre
this doesn't drag the film down however
in fact its strong central performances
breathe
new life into those old cliches this
movie
is a sweet and delightful festive
diversion
and serves a reminder that good actors
can do great work
in any genre pete davidson's turn toward
the dramatic may seem like a surprise
but for the most part
the public seems to have embraced it he
got a whole heap of positive attention
for the king of staten island
and has now earned further praise for a
supporting turn in big time adolescence
this movie follows davidson's zeke a
drug-dealing college dropout who becomes
a mentor to a rule-abiding team
this is a classic coming-of-age story
and certainly features a great
deal of the genre's typical conventions
thanks to a sharp script
and a precise ear for dialogue however
big time adolescence
manages to transcend its formula
davidson
in particular earned praise for his
performance in the film which is a much
more sensitive term than what people
have come to expect from him
the entire cast shines though and
they're a huge part of what makes big
time adolescence one of hulu's best
films untouchable was one of the first
documentaries to tackle the rise and
fall of harvey weinstein
although the technical filmmaking behind
the movie is imperfect
untouchable nonetheless earned praise
from critics in part because of the
urgency of the story that it tells the
movie was released in 2018
a year after bombshell accounts of
weinstein's history of abuse began to be
published across
major media platforms sparking the
hashtag metoo movement
viewers who know those stories may not
learn anything new and untouchable but
this doc
does at least bring them together in a
much wider context
as has become clear in the years since
the weinstein story first broke
the now reviled producer was far from
the only hollywood personality to get
away with horrendous abuses of power
suitably then untouchable examines not
just the allegations against weinstein
himself
but also the systems that enabled him to
hold on to his power for so long
the stories following the creation of
comic book characters are often stories
of credit
about those who get it for bringing such
iconic characters to life
and those who are ultimately brushed to
the side in batman and bill
audiences are treated to the story of
bill finger an unheralded comic book
writer who played a crucial role in
creating batman
it wasn't until after finger's death
that people began to recognize the
massive contributions he made to the
character
but this film asks why bob kane instead
got all the credit for creating batman
even though finger contributed the
character's signature look
his detective skills and many of his
arch nemesis
among other crucial details they would
hire ghost writers back in the day
bob came to get credit for the story
he'd hand it in here's my batman story
like bob york genius and you know that's
how the industry worked for a long long
time
sadly it took years for fingers legacy
to be fully restored but now
at least the world knows that finger
played just as important to role as kane
if not
more so and this movie is one of the
reasons why
run is a taut sleek well-acted
thriller starring sarah paulson as a
highly protective mother and kiera allen
as her sick daughter
the movie takes pains to establish their
close relationship
before things take several increasingly
dark turns
at its heart run is a movie about being
imprisoned without even knowing it
it's also about realizing the person
you've spent your whole life with
isn't who they say they are but while
these thematic elements might feel
weighty the movie itself is surprisingly
light on its feet
thanks to expert work from both paulson
and alan
these broadly drawn characters feel
distinctly human
and even as the circumstances of run
become increasingly absurd
the relationship between the characters
keeps the story grounded with genuine
emotional stakes
lin-manuel miranda is one of the most
prolific creators working today
thanks in part to the success of
hamilton he now has his hands on a vast
array of different projects
often acting producing writing directing
or doing
any combination of those things in we
are freestyle love supreme
miranda helps to tell the story of a
group he started in 2004
years before anyone knew who he was the
group was dedicated to freestyle rap
and this documentary directed by andrew
fried tells their story while paying
tribute to the art form in which they
specialized
obviously miranda is an important part
of this story but he's not
the sum total and even those who might
be worn out by his peppy personality
will find
plenty to love in we are freestyle love
supreme after all
freestyle rap is about creating
something beautiful in real time
and the scenes here that highlight that
sense of spontaneity make the
documentary more than worth watch
although it shares a title with the
famous dostoyevsky novel crime and
punishment is actually a documentary
firmly rooted in the american experience
the film follows latino and black police
officers in the nypd over the course of
four years
chronicling their brush ups against the
system and the ways in which policing is
biased toward people in their
communities
crime and punishment doesn't come to any
easy answers about how the nypd can be
fixed
instead it simply shines a light on the
everyday corruption that's become a part
of policing
and the other systemic abuses every
police officer eventually has to deal
with
nor is crime and punishment a loud
shouting movie instead
it makes its points quietly and
precisely ultimately though
that only reinforces the movie's power
making it all the more clear that
problems endemic to policing
aren't going anywhere it's an urgent
vital movie that gets at the humanity of
the police officers themselves
even as it highlights the corruption of
the institution in which they operate
unlike many of the documentaries on hulu
the subject matter and
vibe of ask dr ruth is pretty easy going
the film chronicles the life of dr ruth
westheimer a sex therapist who
catapulted to fame late in her life
thanks to a tv show in which she
provided candid advice to callers about
their sex lives
what makes dr ruth remarkable is her
utter willingness to discuss sex in a
way
most americans do not she's not shy at
all
and her frankness about sex has arguably
helped spur a new sense of openness
towards the subject
thanks to her slight stature old age and
charming accent
dr ruth has also been able to reach a
whole lot of people who may have
otherwise
tuned her out ask dr ruth as a deeply
charming film but it's also one that
encourages open conversation about
topics that might otherwise be seen as
taboo
according to dr ruth herself sex should
not be a topic we're afraid of
we should be willing to dive in head
first she says no matter what may come
of it
and this documentary embodies that
stance with open-hearted abandon
palm springs debuted fairly early on in
the american covit 19 lockdown
and it couldn't have been more perfectly
timed
the comedy which stars andy samberg and
kristen miliotti follows milioti's
character as she becomes embroiled in a
time loop that sandberg's character has
been stuck in for some time
it's one of those infinite time loop
situations you might heard about
that i might have heard about yeah the
movie has plenty of fun without conceit
but it also updates the groundhog day
formula by asking what would happen to a
relationship
in which both people are forced to
relive the same day over and over again
thanks to note perfect performances from
sandberg and milioti
plus a little help from jk simmons palm
springs is
always charming and frequently moving as
one of the very best
movies that hulu has to offer it
delivers not just laughs
but genuine emotion and a beautiful love
story to boot
with the advent of influencer culture
the world has been treated to an
entirely new type of celebrity and for
some young people the possibilities that
the influencer lifestyle offers is
tantalizing
jawline follows austin tester a teenager
from tennessee trying to make it big
online so he can escape his small town
life
although there are plenty of movies out
there about the horrors of the internet
jawline is not one of them instead it's
a tender look at one kid who's trying to
make it
and a subculture that has a tendency to
consume people like him
and spit them out without ever
acknowledging their humanity
jawline doesn't pass any judgment on its
subject instead arguing that the idea of
internet fame
is so attractive because it offers a
route out of the dead end
something that seems increasingly hard
to find in today's world
sometimes documentaries choose to tell
stories that most people
are already pretty familiar with other
times though they introduce
brand new subjects to a largely ignorant
audience
so it goes in dumb the story of big
brother magazine
director patrick o'dell shines the
spotlight on this obscure publication
which
somehow catapulted a generation of
skaters to fame
and also led to the creation of mtv's
jackass featuring interviews with a
number of the era's icons
this movie tells the story of a
generation of young rebels who
eventually became incredibly successful
within their fields
dumb isn't quite as widely known as many
of the films on this list
but it's earned plenty of praise from
critics who hailed the film as an
effective chronicle of a group of people
who felt like breaking the rules
for no other reason than because they
could
although it wasn't as much of a
phenomenon as the original march of the
penguins
this sequel features all of the elements
that make the first film so winning
morgan freeman returns to narrate the
project and the story at the film center
is just as compelling as anything that
happens in the first film
the next step follows a group of
penguins as they journey to a mysterious
destination
after one of their young hears an
enigmatic call above all else
this sequel which came more than a
decade after the original film
serves as proof that penguins make
deeply compelling subjects for nature
documentaries
of course even as the documentary
wanders at their beauty
it's hard not to see the impending
threat of climate change hanging over
their heads
to that end march of the penguins 2
isn't just about the beauty of antarctic
wildlife
it's also a harsh reminder that it may
not be around forever
too funny to fail is both hilarious and
refreshingly low stakes
the documentary tells the story of the
dana carvey show specifically all the
ways in which it failed to succeed
despite the many talented people working
behind the scenes
stephen colbert steve carell and of
course dana carvey
all worked on the show but that didn't
keep it from flaming out in truly
stupendous fashion
in spite of the show's untimely demise
this documentary remains a fairly
lighthearted look at what went wrong
including candid interviews with all of
these now famous men
as it turns out the dana carvey show may
have been ahead of its time and
too funny to fail demonstrates how well
many of the show's sketches still hold
up
and although its failure might have been
kind of depressing at the time
the story here is told with a wry smile
and the ever useful benefit of hindsight
most magic shows tend to opt for
spectacle over meaning
within and of itself however magician
derek delgadio steers hard into the
world of storytelling
mixing amazing tricks with his own
personal narrative the show becomes an
experience that's both
dazzling and deeply moving in and of
itself is a filmed version of delgado's
stage show of the same name
but it beautifully translates the
experience to screen delgado performs
several tricks over the course of the
show and none of them lose any of their
intense impact through the process of
being filmed but though the tricks may
be astounding they're also pretty deep
delgado show is an examination of how we
see ourselves
and how that self perception helps to
guide the decisions we make
it's absolutely mesmerizing and arguably
one of the best things on hulu full stop
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one